IT'S TIME TO PLAY EMBARRASSING
GOOGLE SEARCHES.
[APPLAUSE]
>> I SET MY BROWSER ON PRIVATE
BROWSING SO THAT MY SEARCH
HISTORY DOESN'T RETAIN THINGS
THAT I SEARCH SEVERAL TIMES A
DAY LIKE SINGLED OUT FAN CLUB OR
EMMA WATSON SPEAK.
[LAUGHTER]
>> I BELIEVED YOU.
>> THEY CAUSED IT RIGHT THERE.
[LAUGHTER]
>> DO THEY HAVE THE RAVEN CLAUSE
HERE?
ALL RIGHT, GOOD.
YOU GUYS HAVE 60 SECONDS TO COME
UP WITH AS MANY EMBARRASSING
GOOGLE SEARCHES AS POSSIBLE.
STARTING NOW.
JUDD.
>> HOW DO YOU FIRE STONED BABY
SITTERS.
>> DAVE.
>> HOW TO AUTHENTICALLY
REPLICATE OLIVE GARDEN RECIPES.
[LAUGHTER]
>> YES, NIKKI.
>> CHRIS HARDWICK SINGLE BUT
IT'S A TYPO THEY REFERRED TO
SINGLED OUT.
THEY WEREN'T REALLY INTERESTED.
>> I'M TOTALLY WITH YOU.
YES, JUDD.
>> ANAL WART REMOVAL.
[LAUGHTER]
>> AFTER A WHILE THEY JUST
BECOME PART OF YOU.
>> YES, NIKKI.
>> HOW DO YOU BABY-SIT.
>> KOECHNER.
>> I AM DBJ.
>> POINTS.
JUDD.
>> TICK TACK LADY SHAVED.
>> POINT.
>> HAS THE MALE SIZE PENIS
CHANGED.
>> I DON'T KNOW WHAT HE'S
RESEARCHING.
POINTS.
>> SOMEONE WHO LOOKS LIKE --
>> IS THAT THE FIRST AUTO SEARCH
THAT COMES UP WHEN YOU TYPE IN
NUDE WOMEN.
NIKKI.
>> ARE PUBE CRABS REAL CRABS.
>> POINTS, POINTS FOR NIKKI.